if you're an entrepreneur business
person or CEO there's one thing sooner
or later we realize and that is that
sales rules the business world and the
sooner you and I turn that into a
science the better you're doing business
and your revenue starts going in the
direction that you and I wanted to go
into so today I'm going to talk to you
about three skills I call it but this
could also be called three different
positions within your company that helps
with sell so let me get right into it
first one is finder second one is closer
third one is developer let me explain it
to you in a way that'll make sense to
you now typically when you and I watch
sales movies or hear anything about
sales you'll hear ABC always be closing
coffee's are for closers right
everything is about closer closer closer
that no one's paying attention to the
finder and the developer so what happens
to most people we don't get good at it
I want you to get very good at these two
areas and you'll see why it's so
important to get good at those two areas
so and at the end of the video I'll also
answer the questions you're on which one
of them is the most important question
important position within your company
so let's get into it in sports so I give
you the analogy in sports great people
who know how to put great teams together
they realize you got to put three
different positions that will lead the
organization it's not three could be
more but I'm just giving you a general
number here in basketball it will be an
incredible point guard a great scorer or
closer and then a great locker room
person for many years I used to ask
myself why are the Lakers paying Luke
Walton six million dollars a year why
because he was an incredible locker room
person Derek Fisher incredible locker
room person you can go back to BJ
Armstrong with Michael Jordan who
brought MJ back great locker room person
you see teams nowadays somebody signs a
two-year four million dollar contract
but they're like 40 years allows you to
get that person to develop nothing more
than to do this to teach the discipline
the mindset sometimes young teams bring
older players to mature the players
right so let's get into sales find your
closer developer find out somebody
that's very good at
one out there networking and finding the
contact so the closure can close finders
get at networking finders good at
exchanging cards finders good at getting
through the front desk assistant to the
executive assistant to the CEO that's
going to buy the products sold by the
closer but if this person doesn't go
through those there is no opportunity
for the closure to close okay the fine
will gets you into massive community of
clientele that all of a sudden one sale
turns into 250 sales that comes to your
company and things change finder
introduces you into new markets get us
find your strengths are very good with
people
they're very trusting people like them a
lot they're make great friends and
they're approachable non-threatening
just very very good at that area right
they make everybody else look good and
it's not about them they don't want the
limelight they're humble they're cool
they're easygoing people like to be
around them now the closer somebody
that's confident very good at asking
questions he'll sit there she'll sit
there go through the questions that
maybe somebody else is afraid of asking
and they'll get to the process of saying
okay you said this is the based on what
you told me you need this this and this
added these three which ones you like
the most I like this quick any reason
why we shouldn't get started sitting not
at all great I don't you know job here's
what go clear let's get the paperwork
started they close that's the closer
closes good at script they know the FAQ
it's almost a science to closure where
they know what questions are going to be
popped up so they do a very good job
with that right and then you have the
developer developer somebody that
follows up with the clients that was
close by the closer found by the founder
by the finder and the developer says hey
Mary how's everything we just wanted to
follow up are you happy
what else can we do for you if there's
anything you need please give us a call
here's a number if you go on a lot
websites you can log on and track your
customer client pop-up of a bug awesome
thank you so much and by the way the
best way you show us that you like our
service is we're commission based
company so if there's anybody you know
that you know feels great about the
product that we service you would place
and that our way we will really
appreciate all no problem I will is then
we can think about right now when we get
back to you great every six to twelve
months he or she follows up how's
everything how's everything how's
everything not to the point us too much
but there's a follow-up right so there's
a relationship being
now I'll tell you most companies don't
even think about this most companies are
here and mainly they're here they're not
even here they're mainly here let me
find the best closer so now which of
these three believe it or not are the
most valuable to sales organization
watch this
most people automatically know what most
people say what do you think most people
will say most people automatically go
right here is the closure
it's the closure and by the way everyone
can have their own philosophy I want to
give you mine and some of it varies
based on the industry on what the price
point of the product is but generally a
lot of people will say the clothes are
the most important person to five I'm
here to tell you I'm here to tell you
the finder is by far the most important
skill skill and position to find and let
me explain to you why every once in a
while you find somebody that has all
three if they do and they have work
ethic it's a guarantee they're going to
make seven figures it's not be the top
in their business at whatever they do
it's impossible for somebody be great
find a great closure and great developer
that doesn't make seven figures only if
they're lazy if they're secretly lazy
there's a reason why they're not making
seven figures but it's mathematically
impossible for economic subjects but
most people don't have all of them like
in a world of basketball this may be
LeBron James great addresses greater
clothing now and he's a great locker
room guy magic locker room guy Jordan
could be this I don't think Kobe is in
this because Kobe is not necessarily too
strong in these two areas but he was
very good here he developed this later
on and he developed us at the last two
three years but not the entire time so
why finder is more important and closer
because closure this can be taught even
this can be taught this can't always be
taught okay let me explore what I mean
this like this can be taught so let you
see yourself any product I would take a
sheet of paper and I would put all these
three products on three sets of paper
and I would say these three products
generate these 10 frequently asked
questions or concerns how long does this
go for is it a contract is it Mon C Mon
do I have to pay upfront what
this happens what if that happens this
product generates these 10 fa Q's this
product generates these 13 fa Q's these
products generate these 16 fa Q's
anybody can learn those script you
master the faq and how you respond back
great if the husband responds back to
concern here husband's typically come up
with these six questions wives typically
come up with these seven concerns okay
great now I have that down this is how
you open up this is how you close these
are the set of questions you ask go take
a couple days and master descript great
if I have a great system I know how to
develop great salespeople same goes here
I find somebody that's warm gentle kind
hey here's how you follow-up here's how
you do this here's how you do that
phenomenal but the finder I can't tell a
finder hey finder hey closer go into
community and learn how to get to know
4000 soccer moms they can't do that she
comes with that because she's a leader
of the soccer moms and she found me 4000
soccer moms to do business with for
instance I can't tell the closer pay
closer go in the community and go to XYZ
and build all these relationship at this
church congregations or this place or
that business or this foursome or that
Cowboys or this other place
I'm just looking at thinking about
businesses finders know how to do that
these guys are irreplaceable these guys
are replaceable because the system can
teach how to sell system can teach how
to sell system can teach how to do this
system finding it takes a lot of courage
to do this closers typically have big
egos closers don't like to go to
strangers and talk to strangers closers
just like to say here's the appointment
I'll get them out close um I got this
Mary can you please take care to
processing yes hey John can you make
sure you give them a call and make sure
everything is fine yes but it's not
going to do this now if you're watching
this yourself and you can wait a minute
Pat I'm a closer I'm a great closer but
but I'm noticing I'm only making you
know three hundred thousand dollars you
I'm only making two hundred thousand I'm
only making whatever your numbers and in
your world you'll know if you're at the
top or the bottom of middle wherever you
are but I'm not one of the best I will
tell you if you consider yourself a
great closer
you will generally find a leak here
generally great salespeople are afraid
of doing this and this your income is so
exponential like if somebody was a great
cause that they learn how to do this
their 100,000 could be eight hundred
thousand and two years three years their
quarter million could be two million
dollar your income in two three four
years literally if you learn how to do
this and if you can ask somebody who
helps you here develop the relationship
now you have a long-standing business
that increases value not just income not
just profit but value somebody else
could come and say I love your business
I will write you check because this is a
valuable business ran on systems and you
guys got all three that figured out if
you could pull that off
it increases the value of yourself of
your business and it just makes
everything so much easier so as you're
watching this video I want you to ask
yourself five questions okay one which
of these three or you get at you which
of these three are you good at so write
it down yeah I'm a good closer I'm not
the best developer and I don't even
focus on these areas of finders great
okay
next which of these three is your
company very good at so you can see well
our company is great at this our company
is great at our company is great at that
okay added the three that you have in
your company which people in your
company are best in each one of them
right on that well I'm good at this is
okay what do you need to do to improve
every one of these areas in this
business question number four and what
do you individually need to do so you
can become more of a well-rounded
salesperson in your company by the way I
love it when people tell me sometimes
while I'm a CEO I'm not a salesperson
I'm a founder but I'm not I'm not I'm
not a salesperson I'm a CEO I'm a
founder I'm a founder which is the word
co-founders to me means sales what else
you think it is if Zuckerberg doesn't
figure out a way to bring the money
there is no Facebook public all
Tunisians yes you need to bring sale
financial firms need to bring sales so
you need to be thinking about sales and
the sooner you figure out how to improve
this and you put a plan of action into
it you'll see like I told you earlier
with revenue is going like this it'll go
in the right direction now many of you
have been asking me and st. Pat can you
do a course can you do a conference will
soon be doing our value taming
conference it'll be the first one stay
tuned we'll announce it it'll give you
six months of time for you to prepare
for it and come to it because we also
have a lot of things going on right now
but prior to doing something like that I
do owe a to our course mm of you have
asked about sales and we'll come out
with a course tell you by it'll be
course you'll buy because it's not going
to be 10 or 20 minute video to our video
I don't know half video and I'm going to
go through a trilogy of how you can
become better at sales and how you can
develop better salespeople within your
company that is transferable
duplicatable teachable where you
yourself can apply and start getting
results immediately and that'll come out
soon I don't ask me what I don't know
when I just don't know come out soon
I'll probably be recording in next 90
days to 120 days but the moment we have
it we'll launch it we'll announce that
you'll hear about it and last but not
least we launch a new series last week
the first one's going to go out this
coming up Sunday it's called pbd real
talk loose if we can put a hashtag up
here somewhere your PVD will talk go on
Twitter whatever questions you want to
ask me ask me anything about business
anything you want to ask me ask it on
Twitter if we like the question we'll
feature your question in one of the PVD
real talk episodes and every single time
at the end of the video I give a I am an
entrepreneur sure to the best question
being asked so make sure your questions
are clear specific to a point and you
give me enough information on Twitter
where I do know how to respond back to
you so with that being said if you
haven't subscribed to this channel yet
subscribe here click here to subscribe
to the channel and if you haven't joined
the notification squad click on the
alert button right next to me to be one
the first to get the notifications as
new videos come up Luis bit late but we
still made it this is the first toss so
congratulations Louis for a good
successful toss you had here we got to
get 2 million subs by the end of the
year I think we close another quarter
again stop here joy notification squad
here go ask your question on Twitter PVD
Real Talk my twitter handle Patrick wait
David take everybody bye-bye
[Music]